comedian and actor DL Hughley has been
entertaining audiences for three decades
now one of the original Kings of Comedy
Hughley is also a New York Times
bestselling author thank you very much
with an Ashley syndicated radio show
available in more than 60 markets thank
you very much on that too
his new book is called I love this title
surrender white people are unconditional
terms for peace DL Hughley joins us from
his home in Los Angeles good morning to
you DL Hughley thank you for getting up
so early with us listen I read your book
over the weekend and I'm so conflicted
because I found myself
well I found myself laughing at times
when I thought should I be laughing at
this starting with reparations you said
when it comes to reparations so far the
only thing black America has gotten is
Popeyes Chicken
what do you mean that the closes weekend
reparations talks work it didn't yeah
reparations talks were hot and heavy
right and then all of a sudden that
chicken sandwich came out of Popeyes and
we haven't heard anything about it since
and they ran out of chicken when we
started liking it but I just the title
is basically where which was basically
happening now started writing this book
a year and a half ago but basically it
is about you know America giving up his
white privilege and is the idea what
that means and just letting everybody
else be a part of the American
experiment and and I think had I known
that all of this that the NASCAR would
be talking about black lives matter that
the NFL would would recognize Juneteenth
and that people would be saying black
lives matter and all kind of arenas that
you never imagined it would it would
have been a shot but the book basically
asking them what they're starting to do
now but that's what I think is so
interesting deal you started writing
this a year and a half ago certainly not
knowing that it would be as relevant as
it is today yeah but the thing about
race in America like black people
America is like a Marvin Gaye song like
mercy mercy me what's going on all those
things will always happen because we
keep coming back to the same places and
rehashing the same things I don't know
that in my lifetime I've ever seen
people to so tune in you know I think
the incidence is you know the Armada
Brianna Taylor and what's happening with
George Floyd and America having to be at
home because of coronavirus we have
their rapt attention it seems like
people are more now tuned to it to a
frequency they never were before I know
but this is the thing that got me deal I
found myself I says I'm beginning
laughing at things that I thought I
shouldn't be laughing at you say for
instance when it comes to black people
and getting arrests I really did you
said in the media you can always tell
what the suspect is when they use the
words what yeah when they say
apprehended and in custody you know
that's the way dude because black dudes
are always shot one is a you know you
see them going to Burger King in the
other is a yellow line with a tarp
across them so you know exactly what and
you know what else is interesting is
I've seen cops more angry with a I've
seen cops more angry with a black
motorist who asked them why they were
pulled over then a dude like a Dylan
roof who just committed mass murder I'll
see the more angry and more active I've
never seen a mass murderer a white mass
murder being walked to a squad car with
people at police when they're trying to
get at him and everybody's trying to
hold him back but I'll see that when
police officers when a black motorist
asked why they pulled over or I know my
rights it's so they seem to me more
angry about someone asking what they're
being pulled over for them then someone
was just murdered nine people something
else that was timely you talk about
racist imagery I mean we just had the
whole conversation about Aunt Jemima and
yet you write about it in your book
what's your take on racist imagery that
America is more comfortable with a black
woman on a pancake box in on a $20 bill
like I mean at one point they were
talking about putting Andrew Jackson on
the
of the 20 and and Harriet Tubman on the
back which is crazy because that would
mean that's a slave on the front and a
slave owner on the back so even when
black people finally make it the money
we still don't have a supervisor so it's
crazy yeah
are you finding that more white people
are seeking you out these days for
advice or just want to have a
conversation I think I think that's
happened that's the phenomenon I've
noticed a lot like I was home
you know shortly after you know the
uprisings and then this older couple
what they do my neighbor for 20 years
they came up and said we're so sorry and
I'm like for what like we didn't know
what was going on and whistles is there
anything we can do and I'm like I've
been here 22 years you could have done
it would have been great 20 years ago
but you see that there's an earnest
there is people are very the interesting
thing is that they're they're people for
whatever reasons were obtuse and make
them up too so maybe they were naive or
maybe they didn't care but I think now
people like I said earlier are tuned
into a frequency they weren't before but
don't you think deal the death I know
this is true the death of George Floyd
right before our eyes has many people
thinking very differently these days I
think so but you contrast a bit of
course it was a horrible thing to watch
and I think it's a video I can't even
watch it now but I think the interesting
dichotomy in America is they're people
who are appalled by what they saw in
that video by the brutality that was
visited on that video but those very
people will fight to keep the monuments
of men who did far worse to black people
there's a there's a statue to a black
man to a talk to a man in New York as we
speak who performs surgery open heart I
mean the guy logical surgeon on women
with no anesthesia Andrew Jackson did
far worse to people far worse and yet
they will be appalled by you know what
happened in Minneapolis and the very
image they saw the fight for the image
of men who did far worse to people yeah
you know we have to I want to talk about
you and your health because we're not
going to show the video but there's
video of you collapsing on stage it
turns out you had folder
you had no idea that you had any of this
right I'm surprised you're laughing
about it it's not funny to yell to see
that tape yeah but you had no idea was
that you even had the symptoms I had it
was it was not funny there but what was
the nothing's actually funny but then
you look at the things around it like I
never knew it happened and then I passed
out and Derrick Derrick who guard who's
my security guard aeroblades who let me
fall apparently so Gary he's a great
security guard but a horrible shortstop
but we were performing in that but I
didn't know what happened and I go to
the hospital and they start performing
all these tests so they one of the tests
they wanted to ask because they're
rivals for Kovac nobody thought they
would come of it but I was being treated
for dehydration exhaustion they drain
the Kovac and I had yeah and so when I
got back to the hotel and asked whether
they were like will you please get out
because black lives matter but not in
the lobby of a Thompson it doesn't but
they made me they made me leaving they
asked you to leave the hotel because I
hotel asks you to leave I was at it
the hotel was laying you have a co VP
like it was all over the news like I was
walking in the lobby and people were
closing the doors and it was it were
understood you know basic about it we
couldn't get weird to get you know
virtual just wouldn't fly us obviously
we had to get a private jet and yeah
them turned us down so I homeless with
Colvin actually make me Vic know that
when that went out with a they was so
ready for me to go they'd even make me
pay for the days I stayed there they're
like if you don't get out of here
if you don't think you leave our hotel
Thank You DL Hughley the name of the
book is surrender white people goes on
sale tomorrow we'll be right back